emitiendo un fuerte sonido
[Música]
el ever given expresa su satisfacción
tras ser parcialmente reflotado después
de casi una semana encallado en el canal
de suez la posición del barco ha sido re
orientada al 80 por ciento en la
dirección correcta la popa se movió a
102 metros de la orilla el presidente
egipcio abdel fatal sí sí mandó un
mensaje de congratulación a través de su
cuenta de twitter hoy los egipcios han
conseguido poner fin a la crisis del
barco atascado en el canal de suez a
pesar de las grandes dificultades
técnicas que rodean esta operación desde
todos los puntos de vista y al
establecer el curso normal de las cosas
con manos egipcias el mundo entero puede
estar seguro de la trayectoria de sus
bienes y necesidades que se transportan
a través de esta arteria de navegación
los remolcadores han estado empujando al
enorme barco y las dragadoras sacaron
más de 27.000 metros cúbicos de arena y
barro de alrededor del portacontenedores
ahora el buque ha quedado recto pero
todavía no está libre
ha llevado tanto tiempo porque tuvieron
que trabajar aún
el buque es probable que estén ahora en
una mejor posición pero no me confiaría
hasta que no lo veamos bajar por el
canal más de 360 buques han quedado
atrapados en un atasco marítimo a ambos
lados del canal
esperando para poder atravesar este
pasaje marítimo vital se calcula que
este retraso podría costar entre 5 y 8
mil millones de euros al comercio
internacional esperando a cruzar el
canal hay material electrónico o ropa
coches pero también al menos 20 barcos
con ganado con decenas de miles de
animales vivos en riesgo de ser
sacrificados por el deterioro de las
condiciones en las bodegas algunos
barcos decidieron que sería más rápido
redirigir su ruta hacia la punta sur de
áfrica si con la marea alta los
remolcadores no consiguen desencallará
leber viven hacia la mitad del canal se
tendrán que bajar los contenedores para
hacerlo más liviano en una operación que
podría durar semanas